hallo ihr lieben heute gibt's bei uns
lecker hähnchenschnitzel sind einer
richtig würzigen knoblauchsoße schmeckt
mir persönlich richtig gut zu reis aber
auch zu nudeln und kartoffeln also ihr
veto tal variierbar und die zutaten sind
standard zutat nichts exotisches und das
ganze geht auch super schnell und
einfach und hier zeige sich zuallererst
die zutaten
ich habe hier hähnchenbrust bereits in
schöne mundgerechte stücke geschnitten
außerdem sonnenblumenöl pfeffer und salz
für das fleisch dann habe ich ja noch
okay ich hab heute tief büro coli
genommen gemüsebrühe butter mehl
petersilie außerdem knoblauch pfeffer
eine prise zucker und etwas salz hallo
heute ist ein schöner tag
ich habe jetzt mein öl in der pfanne
erhitzt auf mittlerer stufe und gäbe da
meine hähnchenbrust hinein und außerdem
setzen wir das jetzt an der stelle noch
mal mit salz und pfeffer und sobald es
dann gar ist nimmt es raus
[Musik]
nach 56 minuten ist unser händchen und
jetzt nehme ich aus der pfanne die
pfanne braucht ihr nicht spülen
wir benutzen die gleich so weiter und
das öl kann auch drin beim dass es gar
kein problem der härte bleibt jetzt auf
mittlerer stufe jetzt gehen wir die
butter hinein und da muss auch fixed die
mittlere stufe bleiben weil mutter sehr
schnell an brennt und dann müsse
dasselbe wegschmeißen von vorne anfangen
die butter ist geschmolzen und schäumt
jetzt auch richtig schön und an der
stelle geben wir unser knoblauch mit
hinzu und dünsten dass eine minute bis
eineinhalb noch mal schön darin an
[Musik]
und diese geschmolzene butter mit
knoblauch riecht schon so gut durch den
ganzen raum hier jetzt gebe ich noch
medien so und dann machen wir eine
mehlschwitze später sorgt nämlich unser
mädchen richtig schöne sämige konsistenz
[Musik]
nach einer minute geben wir unsere
gemüsebrühe hinzu und das am besten in
einem dünnen strahl immer langsam
einarbeiten damit sich keine klümpchen
bilden
[Musik]
nun geben wir unsere gewürze mit dazu
also diesen schönen lächelnden smiley
und die falls euch fragt wofür die prise
zucker das passt ganz gut zum brokkoli
[Musik]
ein tiefkühl roccoli habe ich jetzt auch
mit in die sauce geben das ganze einmal
aufkochen lassen und jetzt müssen wir
eigentlich nur noch warten bis unser
brokkoli da ist es dauert bei tiefen
brokkoli ungefähr 67 minuten bei frisch
und ein paar minuten länger
und dann ist es auch schon fast fertig
ich gebe an der stelle aber auch schon
mal das fleisch mit dem zug an einem
schön warm bleiben in der soße gibt den
deckel drauf und warte noch die fünf
minuten ab
[Musik]
und das war es auch schon unser gericht
ist fertig ich habe nebenbei noch reis
gekocht ich schon erzählt ob der reis
dauert bei mir immer so 18 minuten das
gericht hat jetzt ungefähr 12 13 minuten
gedauert also dauert es insgesamt nur 18
minuten rechts leckere hauptmahlzeit zu
machen
ich gebe es hier noch petersilie rein
das ist natürlich auch nach belieben ihr
könnt auch weglassen oder durch
schnittlauch prinzipien oder sonstiges
ersetzen
es schmeckt auch super lecker
[Musik]
und schmeckt es supergut ich hoffe euch
auch freue mich über eure fotos mit dem
hashtag diskussion ob instagram von
eurem lecken gericht ich freue mich auch
wenn die mehr ein abo der laster mit ihr
nichts mehr verpasst ein dörfchen nach
oben rund 1 kommentar wie euch das video
gefallen hat wünscht euch mehr solcher
hauptmahlzeiten vor allem die die
schnell gehen habt ihr einen speziellen
wunsch schreibt es mir sehr gerne unten
in die kommentare das nehme ich mir
immer sehr zu herzen und dann freue ich
mich sehr wohl beim nächsten mal auch
wieder dabei sein
[Musik]